Thousands of students are graduating every semester.
But there are only so many jobs.
What are employers looking for?
Having a great attitude, a strong work ethic,...
...great communication skills, enthusiasm, analytical skills,...
...those are some of the top five skills that we've seen employers say are very important.
You know what to do according to your personality.
Here's what not to do.
36 percent of employers think the number one mistake people make...
...on an interview is talking too much.
Be careful not to talk over the interviewer.
The meeting should be a two-way conversation,...
...and many people try to cover up their nervousness by rambling.
Another common mistake people make is not doing their homework.
You must learn as much as possible about the company prior to an interview.
Otherwise, you will not be able to hold a well-informed discussion about the company.
Hurry up!
You are late.
Your car broke down.
The traffic is really bad.
Your dog is sick.
These are no excuses in the eyes of employers.
If you are late for the interview, he can be sure you will be late for work.
Don't start talking about money too soon into the interview.
If the company sees you as someone who just wants the money...
...and does not necessarily care about the job, you will be at a disadvantage.
The way you dress can speak volumes to someone who's meeting you for the first time.
Don't sabotage yourself by showing up to the interview like this.
It wouldn't matter even if you're a professional inside.
Stomach butterflies are to be expected,...
...but you can reduce your stress level by avoiding the above mistakes.
Be cool, calm and confident, and you will be on your way to success.